everyone this is Eman this is Nina Wow
what's that believe nation Nina and I
are heading on a vacation to London and
then hop in a cruise across Europe and
you guys are joining us on our trip
[Music]
so Nina and I happen what was that
summer vacation juice our size yeah no
where do you go last year we went a year
before we went to no not Asia oh yes
that was a
I've traveled too much this year I've
had six trips I think I'm ready this
year it's too much I don't like I don't
like it in it oh I got a lot of work to
do but we said we're gonna go Nina has
never been to London so she's excited
I'm gonna show her around and then we're
gonna hop a cruise and go to some new
countries need up some friends discover
some new things eat a lot of bad food
Nina's already studied the crappy diet
today all yummy food but bad for you
yeah and we'll waiting for uber so we
can hop to the airport
[Music]
Nina's never been to a the business
class lounge before what do you think
Nina you all get to 30
what's up in a drink okay news really
excited where'd you get Nina
[Music]
and lots of wine I got a beer Granta
hadn't heard of so I tried that
mac and cheese bread salad Nina's most
excited about the wine I think free wine
you ready to eat we polished off a lot
of food they're mostly Nina
Nina's nice and calm out okay Heather
wine okay Sonny now what are you most
looking forward to on this trip free
food we don't have to go to Europe to do
that you can get at home you know and
and spending you know and I'm amazing we
can happen with your husband with
yourself yeah you get that every day I'm
looking forward to seeing your face when
we do the different sights because when
you see new things yeah you freak out
and you're happy and excited and I love
seeing that is that's what I'm most
excited you I still have two and a half
hours before we leave so we've decided
to Nina made us some hot chocolate with
Bailey's in it
special Nina recipe she's gonna have
some snacks and we're gonna watch some
Marvel agents of shield way to pass the
time
Nina and I ate way too much desertion
Dina we're not used to eating this much
food it's a good thing around the cruise
ship or it can eat tons of food yeah so
we've got about an hour
[Music]
I wasn't seeing the boat on the plane
and we're gonna try to walk off some of
this food so that mean again on the
plane jon is our personal trainer who
keeps us on a very strict diet and this
is our 10 to 14 days to do whatever we
want
yeah
[Music]
what happened Nina there's a Starbucks
behind you I thought you were super full
good thanks is it the first day of
pumpkin spice latte cappuccino maybe
after the walk
we'll see what are you doing Nina too
heavy on your back gotta pack lighter I
think I have for how many days 12 days
13 days in this backpack yeah shuffle
light
[Music]
Nina tried to put too much stuff in her
suitcase and she broke her zipper that's
what happens when you bring too much
stuff people pack light
you're not doing it too full that walk
didn't help the crazy workout and making
in fixing your bag no all right no
pumpkin spice pepper tuna
there it is Nina
Starbucks hello we haven't convinced you
yet let's see what happens
what's what's that over there Nina oh
we're not going team is decided
officially to full can't handle
Starbucks we'll look for a pumpkin spice
in London Nina's crashing it she's tired
let's get her on the plane get her
sleeping and arrive in London yeah
[Music]
alright we had a delay Nina's not happy
about this delay yeah well welcome to my
life like every trip I go on is a delay
that's why he travelling but we made it
on Lena's excited get to our seats get
to sleep and she's gonna eat some more
guarantee
[Music]
this is me or D there's Nina for G
what's cool
you could sleep the line down properly
huh all right
excited yeah you got headphones invested
headphones we got some water in here we
got some toiletries what do you have
okay okay don't get smelly feet okay
what else you got
closing classifications exciting for you
all right good French
[Music]
the menu came to her eating
late evenings supper they want to be
woken up for breakfast probably my
favorite part is I get to watch porn
movies because there's always a good
selection on the plane so I watch the
Chinese one to mean that so there's some
Korean action movies that looking
forward to watching I'm gonna start with
this one assignment Nina on the other
hand wants to watch cartoons
she's gonna watch the cartoon with the
purple hippo and a cat just as a kid at
heart it's partly why we love her also
noise cancelling headphones
so the us trying to tell me something
I have no idea what you say
we're his kids Lane
[Music]
here's dinner
got some steak potatoes red cheese
salad
some red wine
[Music]